on vient chez nous le maire de montréal
denis coderre doit faire face à de vives
critiques encore pour avoir attribué un
contrat sans appel d'offres en soit
encore mis en plus c'est un proche du
maire qui est du contrat oui un proche
du maire robert bouvier
il était le nom vous dit peut-être
quelque chose parce qu'il était à la
tête de l'un des puissants syndicats au
canada tim sturge donc il prend sa
retraite et il a été engagé pour
conseiller faire partie de l'équipe de
négociation de la ville de montréal face
aux négociations qui s'en viennent avec
les policiers donc vous aurez compris
qu'il s'agit d'un ex syndicaliste qui
vont maintenant travailler avec la
partie patronale
ce qui rend pas peu fier le maire de
montréal denis coderre c'est un proche
donc dû mercader l'opposition par contre
est très inquiète elle si c'est la
troisième fois que le maire donne un
proche de nos contrats à un de ses
proches un de ses amis elle y voit une
habitude qui commença à se prendre du
côté du maire de montréal je vous laisse
donc entendre denis coderre suivi de
guillaume lavoie du projet m'ont rien
qu'en fait 30 ans que dans la vie
publique je connais beaucoup de gens des
puis quand j'ai des situations que j'ai
vécu plusieurs situations politiques qui
demandait de poser des gestes et puis de
d'avoir l'audace de prendre une décision
je veux aller chercher des experts des
gens qui vont être capables de faire
aussi le travail puis un élément de
confiance qu'on doit prendre en
considération
bizarrement le contrat il s'est assuré
de le donner pour que personne le sache
un contrat la ville 25000 et plus il
faut que ça passe par les essences
bizarrement celui-là et 24 1999 le seul
endroit où vous allez le trouver
c'est dans un très gros document de 200
quelques pages où c'est écrit en tout
petit donc patrice voilà contre qui
soulève des questions à monsieur bouvier
donc c'est un contrat mais par jour là
il sera payé environ une somme de
maximale en fait de 670 dollars c'est la
somme qui avait été prévu donc vous
l'avez entendu le maire de montréal qui
ne compte par une liste de douze essais
la transparence aussi qui est que
l'opposition met en question dans ce
dossier là il fallait chercher pour me
pour le trouver quoi ce contrat
exactement
très bien merci françois au revoir
patrice